2014 saw the release of a little movie about
a retired assassin on a quest to avenge his
dog.
Thanks to the star power of Keanu Reeves and
some killer fight choreography, John Wick
became a phenomenon, and a franchise was born.
Here's what we know so far about Mr. Wick's
past, his criminal career, his motivations…
and what he intends to do next.
Not much is known about John Wick's early
life, but we do learn in John Wick: Chapter
3: — Parabellum that "John Wick" is not
his real name and that he's an orphan.
When he's desperate for assistance after being
declared excommunicado, he goes to see the
Director, and during their meeting it's revealed
to the audience that his real name is Jardani
Jovanovich, and that his ancestry is Belarusian.
This heritage, and John's status as the last
of his particular tribe, is enough to ensure
him safe passage from New York City to Casablanca.
"So tell me Jardani.
What do you really want?"
In addition to the combat training he presumably
underwent as a young man via the Director,
at some point in his life Wick may have entered
the United States Marine Corps.
The tattoo across his upper back is Latin
for "Fortune Favors the Bold," the motto of
the 3rd Marine Regiment stationed in Hawaii,
which itself is likely a nod to Keanu Reeves'
own Hawaiian heritage.
The John Wick films don't tell us exactly
when or how John became a killer for hire,
but they do suggest certain things — namely
that Wick's chief mentor may have been Marcus,
his friend and fellow assassin who ultimately
takes a contract to kill him in the first
film.
What we do know for sure is that John was
a natural hitman, and quickly developed a
reputation that earned him the nickname "Baba
Yaga".
He was the boogeyman for the most dangerous
people in the world, and he could kill with
tremendous efficiency in just about any way
he had to — including, famously, with a
pencil.
At some point during his career as a sought
after and feared assassin, John did some kind
of favor for his friend Sofia, which called
for her to offer him a blood oath marker which
he could later cash in.
At an unknown point in his career, Wick came
under the employ of Viggo Tarasov, a mob boss
with big ambitions.
Then, though the life he'd chosen was supposed
to be permanent, Wick approached Tarasov and
"asked to leave" because he was in love with
a woman.
Tarasov agreed to let Wick retire, but only
if he performed "a job no one could have pulled
off."
Tarasov does not go into specifics in the
films, but Wick's legendary "Impossible Task"
was apparently a series of assassinations,
and "the bodies he buried that day" paved
the way for Tarasov and his family to rise
up through the ranks of organized crime.
Having accomplished his impossible task, Wick
was allowed to retire from his life as a contract
killer, and Tarasov became one of the most
powerful men in the crime world.
As we learn in John Wick 2, during the "Impossible
Task," Wick also sought the help of his friend
Santino D'Antonio, who secured a blood oath
marker from Wick for his trouble.
After the Impossible Task was completed, Wick
left the world of crime, going so far as to
bury his guns and remaining gold under concrete
in his basement.
He married Helen, and the two settled into
a happy life together.
That happiness, unfortunately, was not to
last.
At some point in the course of their marriage,
Helen fell ill.
The illness was terminal, and she died shortly
before the events of the first John Wick film.
The films rarely elaborate on Helen or her
illness, but we of course know that her death
greatly impacted John, to the point that he's
willing to stay alive if only to remember
her, so that everything he did in order to
have a life with her will be worthwhile.
We can also infer that Helen was a wise woman
who knew that death was coming, and also knew
that her husband would not handle the grieving
process well alone.
To ease his pain, at some point before her
death she arranged for a puppy to be delivered
to his doorstep to help him move on.
The main events of the first John Wick film
begin just days after Helen's death, when
several years have apparently passed since
John's retirement as an assassin.
We can infer this because Viggo Tarasov's
young son, Iosef seems to be the only denizen
of the criminal underworld who doesn't know
who John is.
We know that because Iosef and his friends
decide, after seeing Wick's classic Ford Mustang,
to stage a home invasion and steal the car.
They also kill Wick's new puppy, Daisy, in
the process… and make the mistake of leaving
Wick alive.
When Iosef takes the Mustang to a chop shop
to have its VIN changed, word begins to spread
in the underworld of the sin he's just committed,
while John digs up his guns and gold and prepares
to go on a quest for vengeance.
Viggo berates his son for what he's done,
but still prepares to go to war with Wick,
even taking out a contract to have Wick killed
in the process.
Some of the most talented assassins in the
world try and fail to stop Wick as he burns
through the Tarasov family in New York City,
eventually killing both Iosef and Viggo.
Eventually, the vendetta ends at the chop
shop of Viggo's brother Abram, where Wick
retrieves his car and makes peace.
He returns home and buries his guns once more.
John returns home with a new, unnamed dog
and tries to move on with his life, but his
peace is quickly interrupted by Santino, who
arrives to cash in on the marker John had
given him years before in exchange for Santino's
assistance with the Impossible Task.
John initially rejects Santino's demand that
he honor the marker, and Santino retaliates
by destroying John's home.
John journeys to New York City once again
and heads to the Continental, a hotel that
exists as a sanctuary for criminals with strict
rules governed by the underworld.
After some encouragement from Winston, the
hotel's proprietor, he agrees to meet with
Santino.
Santino wants to hire John to assassinate
his sister Gianna, who is about to ascend
to a seat at the High Table, a council of
crime lords that rules over the whole underworld.
With his sister out of the way, Santino could
claim the High Table seat for himself, but
he can't kill her, because that would spark
a war among assassins.
John reluctantly agrees and travels to Italy
to kill Gianna.
When he arrives and meets Gianna in secret
during her coronation festivities, we learn
that the two are old friends.
Knowing that John is bound by a blood oath
to carry out the hit, Gianna slits her wrists
in an effort to die on her own terms.
As she loses consciousness, John puts a bullet
in her head.
Even as he was honoring the Marker by killing
Gianna, John was under surveillance from Santino's
mute bodyguard, Ares.
In the catacombs beneath Gianna's compound,
Santino's henchmen attack John.
Santino always intended to double cross his
old friend and tie up all possible loose ends
connected to his coup against his sister.
John fights his way out and returns to New
York City, where he learns that Santino has
taken out a $7 million contract against him
as a public show of vengeance for his sister's
death.
Another one of Gianna's loyal bodyguards,
Cassian, attempts to cash in on this contract
and avenge her, but John defeats him in combat
and ultimately seeks refuge with the Bowery
King, who grants him a gun with seven bullets
which he can use to seek vengeance against
Santino.
John fights his way through Santino's guards,
but Santino himself seeks refuge in the Continental,
where one of the chief rules is that no blood
can be spilled on hotel grounds.
John breaks this cardinal rule and shoots
Santino in the head in the hotel's lounge,
forcing Winston to declare him "excommunicado."
In honor of their friendship, Winston grants
John one hour to flee before a contract on
his life takes effect.
"Tick tock Mr. Wick."
Even before his hour-long grace period is
up, other assassins are determined to kill
John Wick.
Seeking refuge, John retrieves a crucifix
and one last marker from a dummy book in the
New York Public Library, and visits the Director.
She "tears his ticket" and brands him with
the crucifix.
This gesture is enough to get him to Casablanca,
where he finds Sofia and uses the marker she
gave him to ask for a favor.
That favor is ultimately a journey to find
the Elder, the only person left who can restore
his status with the High Table and allow him
to continue living his life.
John explains that he wants to keep living
so that he can carry on the memory of his
wife Helen, and the Elder offers him a deal.
If John will show his loyalty by killing Winston
and continuing to serve the High Table as
an assassin, he can go on living.
John agrees to this deal, severing his own
ring finger and giving his wedding ring to
the Elder as a sign of devotion.
While John is overseas attempting to restore
his status with the High Table, an Adjudicator
arrives in New York to dispatch justice on
behalf of the High Table for the wrongs done
in John Wick: Chapter 2.
To carry this out, the Adjudicator recruits
Zero, a loyal assassin, and they begin their
work.
For his role in giving John a one-hour head
start, the Adjudicator tells Winston that
he has seven days to get his affairs in order
before being removed from the Continental.
The Adjudicator then goes to the Director
and, in retribution for her role in letting
John escape, has Zero plunge a sword through
both of her hands.
They then visit the Bowery King.
As punishment for providing the gun and seven
bullets John used to kill Santino on Continental
grounds, the Adjudicator orders Zero to give
the Bowery King seven cuts with his sword.
The Bowery King is severely wounded, but survives.
John returns to New York City after his meeting
with the Elder, but his restoration to service
with the High Table will not be complete until
he kills Winston.
With Zero's men in pursuit, both John and
Winston decide to deny their orders from the
Table.
Winston will not step down as manager of the
Continental, and John will not kill his old
friend.
In response, the Adjudicator orders the New
York Continental to be "deconsecrated", and
a squad of High Table enforcers arrive to
kill Winston, John, and everyone loyal to
them, including the Continental's concierge,
Charon.
Though they initially struggle to fight off
the SWAT-like enforcers with their bulletproof
armor, John and Charon defeat the squad with
armor piercing rounds.
John then goes on to battle Zero and his men,
narrowly walking away victorious.
Winston, meanwhile, uses his defeat of the
High Table enforcers as leverage to parley
with the Adjudicator, who decides to frame
the defense of the Continental as a "show
of strength" from Winston.
To prove his loyalty to the High Table, Winston
shoots John, who falls off the hotel roof.
The Adjudicator agrees to reconsecrate the
Contintental and restore Winston to power,
but when they look for John's body in the
alley, he's gone.
The Adjudicator makes it clear that John remains
a threat to both Winston and to the High Table,
which Winston is all too aware of himself.
John, severely wounded but alive, is transported
to the Bowery King by his servants.
The King, still suffering from his sword wounds
and struggling to walk, makes it clear that
he does not accept the punishment of the High
Table.
The Bowery King declares that he's ready to
wage war against the Table for their attempt
to remove him from his territory, and asks
John if he's also ready to fight back.
John says that he is, setting the stage for
a confrontation.
Shortly after John Wick 3 was released, Lionsgate
confirmed that a fourth film in the franchise
will arrive May 21, 2021, setting the stage
for the war between the Bowery and the High
Table.
"You've got a nasty surprise comin'."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.